here we go here we go double those
points
where's the ticker
get over here ticker
get over here ticker
i was tempted to go for that strike on
f7
oh that was almost a bad castle that
takes pawn
let's get that
what is this what do we even call this
we call that a bad dammit
we call that a bad gamut he was free he
was the freest around
okay so now i'm going to go after f7 i
haven't given up on f7 but not so fast
actually i don't want to drop that queen
and now we're gonna do something
dangerous i'm hitting the knight in f7
that's a problem let's get rid of him
and i'm gonna hit this point a third
time there's some serious issues on f7
and h7 could be made very soon actually
we could see cool mate who takes five
queen here and i have seven will be made
might see a cool mate
so defend h7 f7 if the knight moves his
queen takes king corner queen g8 f7 me
is my punch gonna move
he's handed three times defended once it
can't be defended twice with black's
next move 16 seconds they're gonna let
the time
take away they resigned back to
tournament i guess there wasn't a good
defense there was a well i'm pretty sure
there wasn't any defense i thought we
might see though some smothered me
all right my opponent i'm sure oh the
smith mora no thank you that's why i say
that my opponent
is well aware of the fishing pool and
i'm going to oh they couldn't castle
anyhow
let's do that
let's do that
wonderful wonderful descriptions
what are you going to do
yeah i'm going to do that
i'm going to run away on purpose
um bishop here uh okay i have to give up
my my dark square bishop i'm just going
to castle
take like this i guess i'm going to kick
him away i want to open up the position
my phone isn't castle i gotta watch out
for stuff though
yeah i have to be careful
i have serious dark square weaknesses
serious starts where weaknesses oh
okay i'm not going to take that pawn
that bishop's too scary you're going to
win a pawn though they're going to win a
pawn can we trade
queen trade
i want to get rid of their dark square
bishop get rid of him he's a bad man
pawn push and bishop here okay you can
still take him
hang on they were being sneaky although
i would have queen check and then
recapture h6
this game feels like it's going in slow
motion
where's our quick win there's no quick
wins around
no quick wins here what takes a less
than ten grab a pond lucky time burner
mode i think it is it's time to just
throw in checks and chew up time oh oh
there was lag there i gotta watch out
for the lag that was not a good idea
after all
we trade still
no okay anything anything
finally that clock was not ticking 20 20
12 12 10 and then there's a six way down
below i already feel like i need to go
for f7 strikes okay this knight's pushed
around
with tempo let's push him around still
okay still pushing still pushing
let's push him around
what a bully what a bully i'm being
right now you think you could just push
your phone around like that shame on you
i have h4 covered a very important
detail
let's get rid of him i'm on this
i'm on the rook he can't be defended
imagine that i'm gonna save my knight
i'm gonna push around now oh night here
this is this is where i want to be i'm
gonna get mate right here
that's where he belongs i don't have to
take the rook let me give a check
recapture and then made on e7
i know i'm not going to take the time to
take the queen otherwise there's
queenside castle now that's me that was
fairly quick somebody has 30 though 30
20 17 and then 12s
e6 d5 france did i be that right let's
throw the nimzo or the bogo
at my opponent actually these variations
don't work i have to
i have to go for some other stuff can i
actually still get this out of the name
zone
go ahead take them
my opponent is well aware of my my
tricky stuff
well aware of the tricky stuff
okay give me the b file let me get rid
of the lights for bishop
i want to be on light squares oh
all right let's trade a little bit i
guess this game is not going to end
anytime soon okay end game i want to
play against this pawn keep this
structure
i don't want to take you because i have
to worry about f7 stand this only open
file
this game is not going to end that's a
free pun
let's take here first and that's another
free pawn
let's give a check first probably should
have done that get these guys
in position where are you at you belong
over here
oh let's take that guy run with this
pawn
run pawn you're fast in your past i
think oh i didn't do that
can i still win this i think i could
run king run run run run run
run run run run run is the plan
oh i still have this nine seconds sneak
over
don't drop your rope whatever you do
come on inch by inch we're getting there
you can do it this is this is a dumb way
right over here oh we're dancing i don't
want to dance
finally 1.8
oh know oh if he went the other
direction i would have got him i would
not have got him but in the corner
that's exactly what i need to see he
need to go in the corner oh that one was
grueling
that took forever oh my goodness where
are the quick wins let's block that
let's block that i don't like this kind
of push bishop pen and stuff
okay i can i'm gonna take this bishop as
in between if that happens that's not
happening though he's dropping back
though look at this ugly ugly structure
who's asking earlier about that bishops
he was a bad bishop my opponent just
took him
he was a bad bishop would i just make up
my mind with my lights for bishop let's
go over here i'm gonna secure this point
with my knight if he puts pressure on
him and take him out i'm looking for a
good knight versus bad bishop situation
can i get that oh not really
all right we're gonna have to get this
advance in yep
hang on
oh i got this pawn let's take this
at the end i think i get this pawn
wow i've got a pawn
i've got a pawn and i have to try and
win a bishop end game
up a pond oh i could get this though i
think
okay let's establish a pawn on dark
square first get a bishop trade go back
here and then we got a bishop trade by
force oh no the king is fast now my
king's fast i thought you could sneak
down here okay pass con let's stop
there's moving keep moving mine
they're being sneaky
sneaky again
okay go faster let me have these
hang on was that going to be steal me
just make sure it's not stealing keep
giving check 30 54 40 39 37 i'm not
satisfied with any of these games none
of them none of them
okay i'm on set i'm just not satisfied
until i can get made on h2 that's just
how it is
i need to get my my field h2 we could be
seeing it we could be singing h2 h2
there it is watch out 70 42 40 39 39 37.
elvis chesley
ellis chesley they resigned back to
tournament just like that i got a boost
70-53
let's try it again another one
okay tempo on the queen oh she's gone
just like that
the queen the queen has left the
building the queen has left the building
oh somebody was being clever just there
somebody was being clever who was it
who's being clever
oh my goodness can i just move i'm up a
queen does it really matter
get your pieces out get your pieces out
i actually have dots of h2
h2
h2
h2
there it is 70 65 54. the goal is to
made on h2 every game maybe i could do
it on the white side maybe i could do it
on the white side right i play like um
reverse sicilians i usually just do it
from the black side what's wrong with
this side
i'll take him
you gonna take him he's probably free he
really is he probably is free i promise
it's already dangerous for my opponent
it's already dangerous
bishop there and i have nothing
they're on my recommenders they're out
of the line of fire though we're gonna
have a clean trade army i guess so look
at him he's having a tough day at the
office on d2
okay my king needs to find a new home
and his new home is on e3 i want to pile
up on him who was saying it earlier bad
bishop protected puns i think that's the
situation i was just in
let's defend my second rank my king's
gonna get kicked
let's double
let's go here and then here and then
here
excellent descriptiveness
descriptiveness let's get these pawns
marching where is my time where is my
time
yeah this is going to be
a game that's very difficult to win
where are the time burners
where are the time burners
okay i get this
okay
give a check
no
oh yeah that's what i was afraid of nine
seconds
make sure i get that pawn
give a check yes oh no no no no no
why can't i go fast my king needs to
move help out king do something do
something even if it's wrong
do something even if it's wrong get out
of the way make up my mind
go to the corner back to the tournament
88 70. my heart is in my throat with
that last game
my heart is in my throat my heart is in
my throat with that last game
this is the one minute madness if you're
just tuning in okay put pressure on that
guy actually might be five that's gonna
hurt that would have hurt
it would have hurt okay i think i think
they meant cleaning too to exchange dark
souls bishops i have a pawn presence in
the center let's get him rolling bishop
check my block gonna go queen side
sneaky bishop here
okay they fell for it here that was a
bad move
that was not a good thing to do in a
regular chess game where you make a less
than optimal move and then cross your
fingers and hope that's that's called
bad chest play don't do that ever ever
in longer games bullet it's okay
okay where were we at they resigned from
that position the queen was pinned
another queen is gone take with the king
uncastled
this is not so easy to exploit
gonna help my development know i don't
wanna help theirs i'll spend this night
queenslanders discover tricks discover
tricks
discover tricks where are they
okay they should i should take the
bishop i would have a piece
oh
okay i'm still up um i'll be up
something from this variation so i don't
have to take it tonight you said twice
defended none
now i got that rook there's no bishop
check
there's no bishop check more material i
should be letting very soon
very soon
grab these guys pack me alone and run
the a pun
watch out for steel mates
cut the king off they resign back to
term 123 108 98 85 85 less than 14
minutes remain
less than 14 minutes
okay
let's try some dragon
some dragon maybe e6 and d5
e6 and d5 you take i get this square
knight f knight on f5 is awesome the
knight on f5 is awesome or maybe bishop
here first okay i'm winning a pawn they
don't have enough defense for it here
he's going to stray
let's trade rook on c8 and e8 the open
files
knight 95 is very good here next
tricky stuff on this diagonal
can maybe get at this point
all my pieces working i could have just
done that this comes with check and then
we're gonna have a fork here
i could take that bishop and have a new
queen on the scene
i'm not getting rick at the end of that
probably missed some type of mates on f2
or knight g3 stuff when i had control
over that diagonal
rook
take this pawn next might have two stuff
or not here
nope didn't prevent that threat come on
anything this is not going to finish i
don't think they resign back to termite
143 128 105 105. have to keep winning i
have to keep winning
because there are other guys who could
sneak right up on you
okay that i'm tempted for 95 stuff
a6 i'll play a4
maybe there's no need to do this 95
stuff
oh i guess i'm going to take him
pawn push have to take first because
he's hit twice d5 is a good idea
actually i'm going to go with this maybe
have this tactic might take finally
takes a year to be
careful i'm going to take this i'm going
to break this stuff down queen takes
knight here i'm defining this twice it
was just attack twice development on f4
with tempo
okay and i think follow-up here of a
fork is a good idea
queen here
might be some pawn push with check
rook here doesn't work now
all right now
oh that's me
back to termite 163 126 18. 11 minutes
remaining
11 minutes her name
ts tsba
all right i have my little fort now
built up that is highly highly committal
that g4 is one of the most committal
moves
how am i how do i take advantage of that
why did i just do that
that was dangerous
that was dangerous
get this knight out of here
and then oh he didn't run away
i wasn't expecting that i wanted to
follow up like this yeah i don't want
the knight to be able to make use of
that
where is my room to maneuver let's do
this my knight wants to be here i have
an idea now
knight on c4 this bishop isn't doing
anything take like this open the
diagonal for my bishop i want he's a bad
guy he's my bad [ __ ]
so
so what so let's get rid of him oh
oh i'm so fearful not here i have to
retreat i'm fearful that pawn from
pushing should just play here
okay let's get rid of the dark spots
that's sneaky that's sneaky oh the
knight's dead my knight is dead
my knight is officially dead
okay let me just get castle is gonna
push no i get the rook with queen here
unless there's that move nine seconds i
just get louder there
i just get loud right there i need to
fly oh they dropped a queen that's
exactly what i needed
that is exactly what i needed
anything moves
anything moves four seconds
i should probably take one of the rooks
at one point
time burners is what i need though back
to terms they're down on time 183 146
138 130.
where's my time i have very little time
very little time actually the more that
there's a rating difference the less
time you have
that's where your time is going that's
where your time's going that's where the
queen and now the rook are gone
the queen and rook are gone we might
have a quick resigner
no
okay let me finish my development i
don't care about my knight i don't care
about it g3 bishop g2 watch out for me
bishop here imagine that imagine the
screen imagine the screen just imagine
it it'd been loud never never with
headphones should you listen
clean out
i'm going to attack the
uh king at some point hopefully soon the
knight is now hit he's not defended
throwing that check if is there gonna
block will you really do that
anything
anything
where's the mate there's got to be a
quicker mate bishop here
no that's not me
we'll get in there
he's got to go
why can't i find a mate
this game can i just take this knight
and have the game end
no stalemates
this game he's hiding he is definitely
hiding his main too unavoidable
no it's making one i lied on that one i
was thinking rook
down and over
rook e5 to h5 i think i have a squares
correct e5 to h5 and i realized there
was a main one okay can i maybe i could
get an h2 in
i'll just establish the center knight's
head
it's just no i should take him here
first okay another king he doesn't have
a good home
he's trying to run away but i'm gonna
pile up on this
and come back over h2 i've not given up
on i've not given up on h2 i insist i
insist h2 just like that
223 178.
okay
i need to try and get it on the right
side i haven't done that just yet
actually g3 is unnecessary if i'm gonna
be going for this h2 stuff
what is this this is actually uh
oh i'm wearing a piece now i was gonna
say this is actually an opening that
didn't make it make a whole lot of sense
how is that what it is it's an opening i
think that was um at least the white
setup
i haven't covered enough a little bit of
clean takes now i can block with my
bishop in complete development let's do
it right now what am i what am i waiting
for okay i might end up losing the
exchange or something yeah but i'm okay
with that stay with my bishop get my
bishop back on this lightsaber diagonal
soon
queens are off
the bishop pair versus rook
tricky stuff skewers they avoided that
let's throw my pawn
it's fast
they resigned back to termite two oh
running away two 243 178 175 167 it's
been a while since i did the one minute
madness
five minutes remaining in this
tournament
five minutes remaining
let's try the bingo gambit
the benco gambit
all right now it's not a gambit i still
have play on the b file and i didn't
have to invest any material any pawns in
order to get to that but my point is
coming at me strong here
and this e5 push is soon to be happening
so i want to eliminate the knight who's
watching over e5 and i want to
watch over c4 i'm going to i don't know
here i want to think about pushing maybe
jumping into here one day
d3 my queen doing something i have to be
careful about a night getting here
um let's just try to jump in
jump in no that's just not working the
queen is guarding that dot along a
diagonal so that was not a good idea
um but i'm going to go with this and
hopefully there's still going to be some
pressure that i can have against the
queen side pawns
should i really give that up now this
pawn is passed
let's see what happens here night here i
can take this pawn
not anymore
on takes i take with my king run this
guy twice
i don't want to make progress there it
is i did that i think a five minute game
when in doubt move your h-pawn i can't
come up with a plan here so that's why i
was going with that
what am i doing
what am i doing i'll take that now i
guess i can't be over here to stop this
pawn from getting passed i should have
played up gotta get rid of some of their
pawns can i get rid of this guy okay
he's gone let's come over here and get
him that's how fast my opponent says not
so fast i should have given a check
first let's cut that king off and then
march my own puns
don't have a lot of time
okay let me do that and then this and
then create an outside pass punk
any type of move
don't have any time wow that was a fight
and a half 263 205 204.
two minutes remaining 226.
okay
okay that's what tempo this is with
tempo as well i'm dropping his pawn i'm
defending it
grab some space with tempo same story
here
and secure this point
actually nothing stopping me from that
greek gift sacrifice
right and then jump out with the queen
i take right here otherwise it's a
maintenance seven now
look here one two three four five is me
think something very close to it
no need to mean five
minute two yeah i had myself there i had
control over g7 283 this the guy i
started off playing against
i started off the tournament against
this guy
okay
f3 gaming style oh my name's gonna get
pushed around i guess we are entering
that i've i've wasted so much time with
uh i was thinking about getting my dark
red bishop outside of the pawn chain
but i just want to do e6 and get
kingside castle otherwise i think d5
would have been there soon i'd love to
have lightsweight bishops come off we
have just that so now i can better rely
upon this home on d5
right take steak with my queen that's a
strong post getting this half open or
completely open file i'm on a2 as well i
need a flight square
all right let's take care i should be
able to defend
let's drop that the bishop can't move a
check just in case g7 is an issue let's
do that
he's uh i was defended
okay let's drop my queen actually i was
gonna play bishop here and pin the rope
they resigned back to tournament
18 seconds remain i don't know if this
is even going to start up
jerry squared
jerry squared
is this a sneaky player
is this a sneaky player
having flashbacks of sneakiness uh no
they're calling the tournament
they're calling the tournament just came
up those little
qubits all right first place confetti
let's close out
okay good games ah
all right 303 245 235 i had a lot of
games in there and a couple couple quick
ones there
you